now she's an internationally renowned dj
broadcaster
and events curator and now she's
releasing her debut novel
mother mother by annie mcmanus asked the
question
if you spend your life giving everything
to the ones you love
do you risk losing yourself along the
way
and the dj and now author annie mcmanus
joins me now
very good morning to you hey that is a a
big question you posed there
deep philosophical question isn't it
it is it's a big one jillian i mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of
big deep questions in the book and uh i
guess i should
precede the conversation by saying that
none of it was kind of
uh strategized in that way i didn't
really go out to kind of
answer big questions it was very much a
kind of visceral reaction to
turning 40 knowing that i'd wanted to
write all my life
never really having the time with the
headspace um enrolling in a writing
course
which was six months long and that kind
of afforded me to
to start this novel and it was very much
just these big splurges of frenzied
writing
and finding out what was happening in
the story as i was writing
i didn't really know how it was going to
end when i was writing it so where did
the
inspiration for this this topic matter
come from uh have you lent on personal
experiences with with your own family or
families of
friends people that you know so the book
is set in belfast
in the naughties and the 90s and the 90s
and i actually
spent three years there i went to
university there
and had an incredibly transformative
time there
also the reason why i went to university
there was because my mother
led me there she went to queens
university and she's from northern
ireland so i think unconsciously
i associate belfast with my mother and
my mother's mother
also at the time of writing i had just
come out of the fog of tiredness of
having a new baby and so mothering was
very
present in my world um and i think that
definitely kind of came onto the page in
that way as well
and did you find that you discovered um
more about yourself and your family
relationships as you were
were writing the novel
yeah i guess i did like mary the lead
character and
she has a son called tj the book's about
a woman who disappears so she just walks
out of her life as we know it
we don't know where she's going there's
no plan there's no warning
and she leaves behind her 18 year old
son but but i write a lot about
his early years and and those bits were
very um
it was very lovely to write actually and
i guess in writing them i realized that
i knew how to be a mother if you know
what i mean you know in writing
someone else being a mother and that
kind of familiar um
relationship between her and her son
there was a kind of yeah
a comforting realization that maybe i
knew what i was doing
maybe i don't you ever really do no i
don't think you do i can tell you mother
of three that i am you never know what
you're doing
um did you were you able to answer
the question of when you give so much to
to other human beings does that become
your
absolute focus and you you lose yourself
it was the answer yes
yeah the answer was yes um and and
that's one of the journeys that mary has
to take in the book is
she spent her whole life looking
outwards at other people
caring nurturing just helping other
people stay
healthy and stay alive she's never ever
from a young age
really um had the luxury of thinking
about herself she's never really known
that was something she could do so the
book is about that it's about
finally you know a woman finally being
confronted with herself